[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to
this episode of Click
to Deploy, a series
where we show you
how easy it is to deploy
solutions from the Google Cloud
Marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll be reviewing
how to set up Databricks
via the Cloud Marketplace.
Databricks is a cloud-based
data and analytics platform
used for processing
and transforming
massive quantities of data.
Databricks can also
be used to explore
the data through
machine learning models
and enable teams to use
one platform to collaborate
on data, analytics,
and AI workloads.
Let's start by searching for
Databricks in the Google Cloud
Marketplace.
We'll choose the first solution.
On the solution
page, please make
sure to read through
the overview, pricing,
documentation, and support to
learn more about this solution.
Pricing for this solution
is billed monthly based
on your subscription plan.
Let's click the Subscribe
button to launch this solution.
You'll notice the
Pricing Calculator,
which allows you to model your
estimated monthly costs based
on DBU and time frame.
Start by selecting a plan.
We'll choose the default plan.
Next, choose the
correct billing account.
Agree to the
additional terms, which
are all about
billing and complying
with the license agreement.
Finally, click the Subscribe
button to launch the solution.
Now let's move on to the
next step, which is managing
our subscription on Databricks.
You'll need to register
with a Databricks account
to manage this solution.
Sign up or log in to
your Databricks account.
Let's create a
subscription plan.
We'll choose the
standard subscription.
Next, let's choose Workspaces.
Start by creating
a workspace name.
Let's use the name test-101.
Next, we'll choose a region--
let's choose us-west1--
and a Google project ID.
Choose a name that matches
with the project name
where we subscribe
to Databricks.
So let's use test-ctd.
As you can see, our Databricks
workspace is running.
Finally, let's test the
cluster to see if it's working.
There you have it--
Databricks cluster deployed
with a click of a button.
If you enjoyed this episode,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check out
the Google Cloud Marketplace
and deploy this
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.